well you ready on March there Logan
raided our everybody in Charlotte so
they just did a big x-men universe
Deadpool info-dump let's sit through it
let's just all Loki freaked out about
that book Klaw I love how they slip
stuff like that out like oh you were
paying attention comic-book fans guess
what we totally did all the things so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
talk all about Deadpool the future of
that movie because he basically owns the
x-men universe now cable as well as New
Mutants x-force in the rest of the
movies they're developing this is this
huge info dump there is a new round of
the Logan giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Logan Deadpool related comment on this
video but the big deal first is that
they confirmed that x-force is going to
be a big thing that will spin out of the
Deadpool sequel obviously you need cable
because he's the person that formed egg
force out of the New Mutants I don't
know how they're going to try and weave
the New Mutants movie into the x-force
movie but it sounds like they're going
to be two completely separate things so
if you've never read the comics don't
worry New Mutants is just a comic book
where cable debuted he came back from
the future is this really confusing
story to get tied up in the Age of
Apocalypse this Clone Saga a techno
virus they're probably not going to do
that in the movies they said that they
had this idea for streamlining cables
backstory so he will probably still be a
time traveler and he will still form
x-force he will still try to fight
against the forces of apocalypse and
eventually they can work up to strife
but I don't think we're going to start
off in that place it's just way too
confusing just cable and Deadpool having
a great self-contained adventure with
Domino and a bunch of other deep cuts
from the x-men universe that will also
tie in with x-force so you have to
imagine that even though they might
choose to cross Deadpool over with the
main x-men film because he's kind of
like their Hugh Jackman now the
Wolverine characters that everybody
loves you put them in a movie and it's
like oh my god I got to go see it
because I really love this character so
with that in mind
Deadpool now owns the x-men universe
even though they're also talking about
ramping
up into production for this next x-men
supernova movie Simon Kinberg is sort of
like the Kevin Feige over at Fox for all
their Marvel movies so he's mostly in
charge of this next big x-men movie all
dressed that in a second but they're
trying to keep Deadpool as separate as
possible just because his tone is so
different from the normal x-men movies
so just like Marvel kept the guardians
of the galaxy separate from the main
Avengers films and then worked up to a
crossover the same thing will probably
happen with Deadpool so Deadpool is
spinning off x-force that'll kind of be
a separate thing for the main x-men film
so the future of the x-men universe is
really cool but you have this big
dividing line where you have everything
that flows from Deadpool and everything
that flows from the main x-men felt so
largely Deadpool is going to be driving
the x-men universe because Marvel is
never going to do an r-rated comic book
movie infox has had a lot of success
with that everyone is going crazy about
Logan that doesn't guarantee that
x-force is going to be an r-rated movie
but they just hired on someone to write
the screenplay and direct it looks like
it's going to be joe carnahan he's been
working on it for a while now so that's
really good news but Simon Kinberg also
basically laid out the movies that
they're developing right now they're
pushing deeper into the x-men universe
and they're going to get a little bit
weirder with their characters it'll be
less cookie cutter so they've already
started working on new mutants we know
about that that's basically a teenage
version of x-men I think if new mutants
is successful that will be like their
spider-man franchise like Marvel is
using the spider-man character now as
it's sort of teenage character the film
that really young kids get super excited
about now I mean young kids get excited
about all comic book movies but there
aren't a lot of protagonists in the
Marvel Universe that are really young
and that's really where the new mutants
fit into the x-men universe because most
of the main x-men are in their late 20s
way older so they're just diversifying
the same way that Marvel's diversify in
the other really cool thing and this
isn't a spoiler for Logan or anything
like that but they did confirm that x-23
would probably get her own project
eventually or show up in somebody else's
film they'd have to be kind of careful
how they use the character because the
Logan movie takes place in the future I
think we can all agree that as long as
the character is awesome and it's cool
story will be totally
if they ignore the continuity they've
been doing it for the last ten years
it's not that big a deal but if they're
going to do a young version of the
character and she won't be like New
Mutants age then they would probably try
to work her into the main x-men films or
they would try to include her in x-force
if they want to age her up and she can
be super hardcore I feel like we'd be
much more excited about a hardcore
version of that character than a super
tween like the more teenage version in a
New Mutants movie now there's still a
bunch of questions about what the future
that character is going to be what
they're going to do with Wolverine I'm
going to save a lot of those videos till
after Logan comes out and if you're on
the fence about it
go see Logan it is an amazing send-off
for Hugh Jackman saving the best for
last the next big thing is the third
Deadpool movie they've already planned a
third Deadpool movie they don't know
what the story is beyond the idea of
forming the x-force team like literally
making that happen inside the Deadpool
movie so it's not going to be like
Deadpool to cable cut to an x-force
movie it'll be Deadpool to introducing
cable then Deadpool three with cables
introducing x-force so I was not kidding
when I said the Deadpool owns the x-men
universe now because any x-men movie is
going to earn a lot of money but I feel
like Deadpool is the one that won the
fans over so that's what most people are
going to come back to but mr. sinister
the big-ticket news items so everybody
was wondering after x-men apocalypse
what is going on we hadn't heard
anything about him in the Logan movie so
it's like did you just forget about him
is he going to be the villain of the
next x-men movie what's the deal because
initially it seemed like they were
teeing up stuff for the Logan movie but
then the director came out and was like
no no this is just intended to be a
self-contained Wolverine movie since
then the x-men powers-that-be have come
out and said yes we do have plans to
introduce him into the world short
answer is yes we would love to see mr.
sinister but they didn't get too
spoilery so they didn't say when he's
going to pop up how he's going to pop up
it's just as a Nathaniel Essex tag at
the end of Apocalypse was such a big
deal that of course they're going to
follow up on it it just they were
confirming because a lot of people were
like hey if you don't say anything we're
going to assume that you're not going to
do this and you're just going to forget
about it
like you forgot about your continuity
but there's so much chaos in the x-men
universe right
now and they did this big info-dump like
I just talked about Deadpool the main
x-men film in what's going on with
exports that's just the tip of the
iceberg they said that they're
developing an exiled film alpha flight
all these other weird x-men universe
characters they control hundreds and
hundreds of characters but those things
are less real than even like the third
Deadpool movie which they haven't even
started working on yet speaking of which
you may have heard the Drew Goddard
actually came on to Deadpool to to help
them finish the script so the original
team is largely still in place but
whatever was happening with the script
they were having some problems so he's
the guy that helped launch the Marvel
Netflix series he did the first season
of daredevil he was also developing the
sinister six movie at spider-man he's
sort of part of that pantheon of
comic-book super producers super riders
who just do really amazing stories so it
makes me really excited but they haven't
revealed too much about what the actual
story is beyond and just teaming up with
cable so there's a couple big cable arcs
they could adapt for the movie but it
sounds like it's going to be an original
story in the same way that the first
movie did his origin story but was
largely original they changed a bunch of
stuff so if you're looking for a cable
and Deadpool a team-up story that's
relatively safe for the movie something
that they might actually consider doing
cable and Deadpool if looks could kill
it's really good Deadpool the good the
bad and the ugly is also a little bit
bigger than I think they're going to go
it's been going to North Korea with a
bunch of Deadpool clones so I'm not
expecting something like that but they
might get into clone stuff because of
mr. sinister in the teaser at the end of
apocalypse just because mr. sinister
himself is so obsessed with bloodlines
in genetic tampering and I know a lot of
you are asking about that Hulk Wolverine
teaser that's a comic book thing I'll do
a separate video about that because if
they're doing what I think they're doing
it is going to be crazy but it has
nothing to do with the movies so don't
worry about it it's just a really big
thing that they dropped casually it's
just that they could totally share mr.
sinister with the Deadpool movies in the
main x-men movies he's that big of a
character without necessarily having to
put him in the Deadpool movie because if
they can do all that discount x-men
mansion joking Colossus negasonic
teenage warhead then they can totally do
mr. sinister Essex corporation stuff we
actually sticking mr. sinister himself
in the movie they could always offer a
suicide King storyline that's Deadpool
trying to clear his name for murder he
did not commit even though he does kill
a ton of people it involves a lot of
spider-man daredevil stuff that they
obviously can't use so that involve a
lot of changes of that story but like
dead presidents all the zombies stories
but you can let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with the
future of the x-men universe do you want
them to cross Deadpool over with the
main x-men film or like they say they're
doing right now
do you want them to keep them separate
and just to bring it back around a table
what do you think about the idea of Ron
Perlman vs. Russell Crowe versus say
like Stephen Lang now Rob Liefeld said
that they're auditioning every male
actor in Hollywood for cable it's like
one of the hottest roles out there so
whoever they get it'll probably be
someone within their budget someone
that's not like a twenty million dollar
price tag so I'm not expecting Russell
Crowe but Ron Perlman is actually pretty
attainable I mean he's a really big
actor but he's not like twenty million
dollars big so even though Deadpool is
stealing most of the attention in the
x-men universe right now there's still a
lot of x-men stuff happening this year
I'm actually really excited about New
Mutants just because it's a really small
property and I think it has a chance to
surprise people but let me know what all
the questions you guys have what kind of
bonus videos do you want me to do for
this in the comments below what's going
to happen next is I have new Game of
Thrones I'm going to post then there's
new Walking Dead and then there's new DC
TV big four night crossover stuff that
we'll post on Monday congratulations to
Noah hang you won last week's Logan
giveaway please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there's a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
an x-men universe video while you wait
for that you can click here to learn all
about iron fists and defenders season 1
and you can click here for all my other
Deadpool videos thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys in the next video